[Musique]
sur sérieuse en face il a licencié la
camair moi je dis non
les stars ont fui la zone et puis
sérieux est the world non mais moi non
faut dire c'est vrai moi j'aime beaucoup
albert a depuis longtemps
vous m'avez demandé le rallye vos rêves
d'image au fort solide c'est comme une
bande dessinée les bandes dessinées mais
les jeux beaucoup quand j'ai pris alors
j'ai dit oui ça me plaisait puis j'aime
beaucoup faire livrer ce crâne puis
après ils veulent saper les sentiers de
la création du pôle ça m'a fait froid
dans le dos qu'est-ce que je suis
pratiquement rien laissé m'ennuyer je
suis trop polis et un césar en titre de
parler un peu des sentiers les aérations
proprement dit
parce que moi je crois toujours en
majeur espérience arrêté enfants ont
expliqué les fassions par la suite toute
réflexion faite mais serait fait
explique un soutien concret alors la
migration ne me fais je pars un peu pas
grasse et les gens m'appellent pas une
chose qui peut intégrer à bhl parler de
match m dans ce livre je la fais de
merlieux collage
socialiste le plus tard on m'a joué des
plages comme ça je serai avec des
ciseaux de la colle on peut faire les
images analogues on peut pas réussir
nous mêmes comme des images ou des deux
littéraires des métaphores les
associations de mots oui j'suis toi ce
fait j'aurais quoi la pataphysique cité
véron dans le xviiie à paris
c'est là où on voit the boris vian c'est
toujours mon voisin voilà maintenant
c'est ma voisine de sa femme
je suis là c'est pour ça que beaucoup de
beaucoup de matchs crise post cité véron
c'est une place de la création c'est pas
un centième c'est une peu sa main un
marécage de la création
il ya un livre de caricatures vient de
paraître à rien en disant bien longtemps
c'est un moyen d'expression qui n'a plus
sa raison d'être dieu a créé l'homme son
et image et aujourd'hui grâce à lui la
télévision petit écran montre
journellement la vente et auto
caricature des grands de ce monde
je n'oublie pas besoin de seulement 3,9
alors on est en deuil mais la meilleure
la pause et a que ça rend il l'a quand
on les voit en eux mêmes sont là on est
plus en deux allez voir c'est pas la
peine
féru glisser dans pearl et c'est ça rend
inutiles avec la nature allawi c'est
fini
quand je vois les jeux super évolué
alors des noms évalué que tu vois
maintenant il va lever comparaison va
faire caricaturer pages que toujours de
vous poser ça va super ccd rose je peux
ça parce que la petite sorcière le
terreau semis
alors elle aa pas été bien avec heures
il rappelle que le web parce qu'il parle
crise quittent le faire c'est que la
forêt pas titré el malah l'on imagine
qu'en dehors du drapeau ou à l'hymne à
lui et à la sorcier à la dame sorcier la
douce sorcière nicotine
face aux deux images - le succès est
donc une garde sa saison beaucoup
bonjour a beaucoup nouveau patch console
intéresse autant chose de plus
intéressant
il ya des millions de gens sans les
misions êtes jeune homme de 25 ou 30
gare d insérer ou 2000 je crois me loin
lyon meilleures choses intéressantes
la télévision c'était un très beau
spectacle
rihanna près de vue par une seule
personne n'a jamais rien vu mais je vous
serai bon parce qu'on a fait par la
suite
c'est un peu comme tout commerçant
deuxième chaîne troisième chaîne
quatrième chaîne cinquième chaîne
c'est comme si citron moment désagréable
avec man mouchard mois le flic
même le tout avec toujours comme la
relativité une version plutôt restreinte
pouvais pas
elle disait
mais j'avais essayé du ventre avant
qu'ils aient saignait du nez
bien sûr je sais le pas comment ça
marche et le corps l'atelier à souffrir
la machine à plaisir à rêver rêver un
jour je rêvais de boue sur le quai
devant une vieille gravure une planche
de dissection et jolies femmes aux
épaules nues ou plutôt des loups des
débuts du avec l'apport abattu de chaque
côté orrespondant du cera lé manteau de
chair à doublure écarlate sanglant et
tendre décolleté mais ce n'est pas
tellement terrible sais pas s'il est
simplement qu elle aiderait je veux
parler c'est comme ça tout le monde
intérieur avec urines
ma mère de l'amour le sens que les pieds
à la tête et de la tête auteurs le
bestiaire les superstitions à ses rêves
la ménagerie des religions ses cages du
rire il est lourd qui me fait toujours
aussi aussi anticlérical sur le rien
dire pour moi le mot anticlérical on
sait rien dire parce que les puits
tout ta jeune j'étais intact ce qu'on
appelle dieu absolument atteindre mais
j'ai fait nos propres millions j'ai
appris le catéchisme sa marine comme
intéressé de voir qu'on pouvait talent
et on l'appelle elle a été premier à
appeler à des mensonges premièrement et
mon père j'aime beaucoup mon père mon
père m'avait acheté une mythologie
on vous y apparaît toujours le cas
celui-ci ça prend le château lui te lie
notre logis à la magie c'est merveilleux
parce que c'était lui l'homme d'abus non
c'est celle des ds3 et belle fille les
gens jetaient un peu mauvaise péter sur
la gueule satis mme bazy la guerre mais
parle mais on sait pas que ont été
responsables connais ça se termine comme
ça la connaissez vous la romance la
romance du môme unis les romances du mot
muguet elle finit comme elle commence la
romance la romance il n'ya point de
pointe initial alors pourquoi un point
final vous n'y a pas de sentier
finalement
josé jamais commencé défini moi j'ai des
enfants je suis entré des gens personne
ne m'a priée d'entrer dans ma 71e année
que personne ne m'a dit non plus sans
l'apport sera fermée alors j'attends
avec impatience mais je vous la fenêtre
mais je bois je me sentais à chanter les
amis
[Musique]